what's up my fellow geeks zacky here
from geek culture with another unboxing
of songs as you guessed it
as you can see relive the legend legend
of what if this doesn't hint to you
this is the mass effect legendary cash
okay cache cash i'm gonna say cash hey
because that's how we do here in geek
culture and i'm saying
anyway
without further ado
let's have a tour of the box
i'm not sure if there's the front i'm
just gonna say this is the front
uh yes we live the legend
you have a glimpse of commander shepard
with his helmet
all right at the back again repeat
and just some extra stuff
especially the
the bioware e
logo here
uh it contains a one-to-one scale
wearable replica helmet with led light
effects a metal hard shell game case
a limited edition art print
an enamel spinner pin
and a printed n7 welcome letter
of course this helmet is only attended
for cosplay and provides no real
protection and requires two double a
batteries
so that being said let's go ahead and
get this unboxed
and the first thing that comes out of
this box is of course the welcome letter
all right
y'all can feel free to pause this and
have a read for yourself
i just like how it's uh
it says congratulations on your
graduation
very very very cool nothing at the back
i'll put this here
all right
and
here we have
the prince so let's take this out and
see what it is
it's all about
taking this out
it's nicely wrapped for protection
grab some paper too
i'm not going to do a very good job
and taking out the tape
[Music]
it's just nothing like christmas
and it's uh yeah man so it's a nice
canvas print if you think about it
so we got a
female looking commander shampoo
it's a nice canvas print too so it's a
really nice texture
nice hard back too
yeah feel free to mount this on the wall
man for you mass effect fans
and i believe there's going to be
another one the second one over here
again
not very good at
unwrapping this
this time we have a canvas print
of the normandy
very cool this is nice
i i take this one it's really cool
get canvas print
hardback
this is the
pin
it's a two pin
cam thing
get it close to the camera this is of
course the renegade
logo and it's a spinning pin so once we
remove the two pins on the back
pin holders
paragon logo
of course you can spin it
depending on who but i'm team paragon so
you know
yeah team fairy god
spin it oh
yeah okay
it's like a little fidget pin
spinner of sorts
very chao
we have a steel hard boot case
to store your game
unfortunately
we
do not have the game
that said
but
nonetheless
pretty cool huh
got a nice n7 here
again commander shepard's um bust
if you will
and you have the
mass effect
legendary edition
on the spine of the book
very very cool
for the psala resistance
first
we have the
n7 helmet users manual
on how to
install the batteries
we won't go into that in further detail
uh of course you can have the download
domain online i guess
and it shows you how to adjust the n7
helmet to fit as well
now of course this is the moment you
guys have been waiting for
check out the helmet
so
oh
there we go okay
i'm gonna take
the box away
right
and we shall unravel
the helmet gas
very cool
check it out
isn't this awesome
it's great
in all of its glory
very cool
even the back here too that's awesome
nice n7 logo as well
very interesting now
you look at the it's not really vent
holes where you get some textures here
as well and a chin guard it's what the
top looks like
it kind of reminds you of um
star-lord doesn't it
[Music]
right the visor as well the visor is
pretty transparent let's check out this
weathered look
you know all across
it's kind of like carbon fiber
looking um detail
but you can actually feel this
it's all textured it's not like a
sticker or anything like that
and just the complete weathering on all
the edges and sides
if you look at there
so you can see even the edges
here
are kind of kind of weathered
as well
it's almost as if it's rusted
a little bit or aged
in space dust
wall has some sort of weathered look as
well
and of course don't forget
the entire sticker it's a very nice
touch
as well
it's it's completely
embossed
so it's not like a sticker where you can
peel it's it's really in there it's
molded in there them painted
from the underside of the helmet this
one looks like
so let's compare this helmet
with
some other
helmets that we have here in the geek
culture studio
all right so we got ourselves two other
elements of course you've probably seen
this this is the
hasbro black series mandalorian helmet
of course we also have this iron
punisher
from hasbro as well
and
you can see
the green and close to close
they look pretty much similar in size
but in my view the mass effect helmet
right here the ends of the helmet
looks a little taller
if i just put my hand you can see yeah
it's it's it's a little taller
let's let's do a comparison from side to
side too
i think
if i were to just take the mendel helmet
[Music]
you can also see that the commander
shepard's helmet is a little bit wider
than the mando helmet as well
all right
so
without further ado i think the only way
is to wear it i mean it is for cosplay
so
of course you gotta wear it
excuse my hair and did not do it today
so
does it feel glasses too i think that's
the main question isn't it
so
it fits
it fits
yeah
i like how the
the chin guard itself it's blocking so
you know you guys can see my double chin
but
now i could wear this all day actually
now i wish the visor itself
is a little you know a little more
tinted
also you can probably see my face
through
the
visor
this has lighting effects as well and
it's a button around the back
it's a very spacious interior too just
trying to figure out where the button is
you don't really have to like
squeeze your cheeks into it like the
mandalorian or the iron punisher helmet
as well
there is a battery casing
over here there's a three-way selector
switch
right here by default at the center is
to turn it off
if we shift it to
the left
then you have the red lights
okay
let me use this as a
stand
you can see that the red lights
glow
all right and it's not just the front
of the chin guard over here
do have some
red led effects
right
just above the visor line
as well
and
look at that
this this is a nice touch
red leds at the back as well
okay
and if we slide it to the right
there you go
i don't know i don't know guys
i don't know whether the
the red or the blue
looks like so
i i i i'm a sucker for blue colors
though
this is really cool check out the back
as well
and it really glows and you can see
whether it looks even better in the dark
oh yeah
[Music]
that makes me want to play the game
again
it's very nice
i'm just going to turn my head back
so
you can see
close
very cool
yeah
i dig it i think i prefer the red it's
more menacing
if i can reach the battery pack
there we go
i am commander shepard and this is my
favorite helmet on the citadel
you know it could have been better if uh
he had some
kind of synthesizer but it's really
great the interior though the interior
is very different compared to
like the mandalorian helmet you really
see all the wires
in this helmet
where are the lights and doodads and
everything but i think it provides that
aesthetic purpose
you know
it's sci-fi so we we have no clue what
is
technically right or wrong when it comes
to the interior of helmets
but i like it it's roomy it's very roomy
it's very spacious
and you know you're not gonna have a
hard time if you're gonna cosplay as
commander shepard
you won't have a hard time wearing this
helmet
and uh by default i mean the fitting for
me
and it's a little bit of give but you
know i think i prefer that of course you
can adjust the straps to make it a
little tighter on the crown of your head
but
i dig it
i think it's very nice
i think i look badass actually
what do you guys think
let us know in the comments down below
yeah
so with that's it hope you enjoyed this
unboxing of the video it's gonna it's a
quick one guys you know all the details
are in there but you know what's better
than me talking about this helmet
more b-roll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's it we hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did do give us a
thumbs up and
if you haven't already consider
subscribing to our channel and smash
that bell icon so you can be notified
every time we upload new videos
until then this is zacky
signing out
adios
[Music]
you